it's always uphill battle with the
treasury no matter what department
you're in it's it's the right thing that
a secretary of state will argue for an
increase to meet their priorities and of
course between now and the budget I've
got lots of time and lots of meetings
with the chancellor to make sure that we
uh try and come to a a deal on it and I
think uh you know I haven't hidden the
fact that we suffer from inflation
pressures as does departments with big
Capital spending that's that's spending
on hardware and infrastructure because
of course that's where inflation goes to
but um you know we'll see I mean I'm not
going to conduct the negotiations in
public but uh obviously we're going to
try and make our way through this so
that between now and the next spending
review which is in two years time we can
insulate defense from many of those
pressures